Tammi is with us in Georgia hi Tammy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up um I'm having buyer's
remorse my husband and I back in
September purchased a vehicle and my
backstory is I am a senior manager with
an automotive manufacturing and I
receive a car allowance of $800 a month
and so we you get the car allowance or
they buy the car or not you know you do
have to have a vehicle either you have
to purchase one or you have to lease one
in order to keep the economy on from
them
yeah okay how do you work for lease on
okay okay so the but the deal they're
offering you at Nissan is it's
maintenance it's everything right yeah
it's a bargain
this is not this is not a car purchase
this is an employee benefit yes yeah I
mean what they're giving you don't think
you've you tires maintenance gas
everything in the deal yeah yeah and you
can't drive a car that cheap anywhere
else so and you don't even have like a
pitch you can turn it in one month at a
time right here a year okay you keep it
a year you can flip it around every year
if you want to but it's not it's not
like a normal car payment or a normal
car lease no I if I worked for Nissan
I'd be doing that deal we purchased a
truck I mean my thing I was trying to
reason with my husband that no I'm sorry
you didn't do the Nissan deal are you
actually bought a truck or you're you're
doing the Nissan dealer truck okay so we
bought the truck but so they give me the
$800 in my paycheck every month
oh why didn't you do the deal where they
pay for everything that will be leasing
it and I told him I said I have to get
the 800 every month anyway
let light as well by your vehicle and
that $800 they can pay but now you got a
car payment now you're in debt yes I'm
trying to convince him to sell the truck
yeah no I would do the deal over at the
lease with them is not a standard car
lease unless the unless you all have
changed your program at Nissan it's a
it's a it's a rental program that
includes all of your maintenance all of
your insurance all of your tires
everything is built into it and you
can't drive a car as cheap as that is
their lease program is an employee
benefit it's not a lease like a regular
car lease and so that's the way I would
do it I wouldn't buy a car going into
debt and get a car allowance from them